beautiful I also really liked the last
sequence of for game against chlorograph
where she sacrificed the queen at the
end and the whole sequence leading up to
that I was I was sitting there watching
and like trying to guess
um the moves and I could see it
unfolding and I I thought it was was
really pretty I'm worried about you I
think with her she is she also obviously
had a very very difficult childhood it's
not necessarily down to her being a
pretty new chess player that she
experienced this
these difficulties from my own personal
experience I wouldn't say that I've
suffered at all I've had a fine
Balanced Life and
apart from that I've been able to do
what I what I love so I think it's it's
at least not an automatic but being
brilliant at something
takes away from something